[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday January
21st and today's video is in one way
exactly like Fyodor Dostoevsky's The
Brothers Karamazov
it's about patricide no it's about
freewill no oh wait does it come in four
parts yes
part one puppy-sized elephants hank in
my last video i wrote an open letter to
evolution requesting that evolution make
me a puppy sized elephant because it
would have the evolutionary advantage of
being adorable now Hank we all know that
evolution can take several million years
to respond to requests so in the
meantime all these made of awesome
nerdfighters made me all of these
puppy-sized elephants I'm sorry Hank but
puppy-sized elephants just blow puppy
sized puppies out of the water I mean
Hank just look at them and Hank as I
look at all of these puppy-sized
elephants I can't help but think man I
wish there was a Photoshop for reality
you know so you could be like this looks
pretty good but I'm wondering if there's
any way to maybe dwarf down the
elephants nerd up the humans and maybe
take that malaria layer and just get rid
of it altogether also just a general
recommendation more rainbows part two
puppy-sized elephants continued Hank the
saga puppy-sized elephants does not end
with Photoshop right after I posted my
last video several brilliant
nerdfighters pointed out to me that
evolution did in fact make me a puppy
sized elephant albeit many thousands of
years ago so there's this evolutionary
phenomenon called insular dwarfism which
over time causes large animals and
isolated populations to breed themselves
smaller so Hank say you're a large
animal and you are during an Ice Age you
use an ice bridge to head over to an
island and you like the island so you
stay there then the Ice Age ends and all
of a sudden you're a big animal stuck on
a small island over many generations
you'll breed yourself smaller so that
the population can continue to grow
despite limited resources the phenomenon
of insular dwarfism has been seen in all
kinds of large animals like dinosaurs
and humans and elephants Hank I'll be
the first to admit that the puppy-sized
elephant would be cuter if it were not
so dead but still pretty cute it turns
out that there were several different
kinds of miniature elephants some of
which were so small that they were only
like three feet tall Hank it's believed
that the last species of puppy-sized
elephant went extinct about
years ago it's not clear what killed
them off but it might have been people o
people
why must you ruin everything in fact ank
if I ever do get a letter back from
evolution it's probably going to go
something like this dear human thank you
for your letter
we made you a puppy sized elephant but
then you killed it
fancy that you're welcome for your
thumbs evolution part 3 my glasses
Hank people are still hating on the nerd
glasses take a few passes and apologize
to us I'm sorry if they upset people but
I'm not taking off my glasses why not
cuz they're famous part for projects
challenges and punishments nerdfighters
you've been talking so much about how
much you miss punishing us that we've
devised a way you can keep doing it
here's how it's going to work we come up
with projects for you and then if and
when you complete those projects as a
reward you get to punish last challenge
us in whatever way you see fit
although the wives still get veto power
so for instance after the stunning
success of the first annual project for
awesome you would have gotten to punish
us and nerdfighters were ready to
announce your first project many months
ago Hank wrote a song about Helen Hunt
your project should you choose to accept
it is to make sure that Helen Hunt has
seen that video and provide proof that
she has seen it if you can pull that off
you can punish us both
hey is this Orlando Bloom yeah no it's
John green of the vlogbrothers right
yeah no I know I know it was funny that
Harry Potter song I'm going to need you
to put on your elf ears and get out your
bow and arrow yeah well I just received
word that they're taking hangry into
Isengard and I'm gonna need you to go
you know get him